[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARC STOGAITIS: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
My name is Marc Stogaitis
and I lead the Location
and Contacts Client Team.
And with me are Wei Wang,
Steve Malkos, and Souvik Sen.
And we're really excited to
be speaking with you today
about what's new with
Android Sensors and Location.
Now we'll start by discussing
some of the upcoming
changes to background
location, and how
you can prepare your application
for the Android O release.
We'll then discuss accuracy
improvements to location,
improvements to
activity recognition,
as well as sensors.
So let's get to it.
Well, I think we've
all experienced
that terrible feeling
when your battery is just
about to run out.
It's a beautiful day outside,
so you decide to go for a hike.
And after several
hours, you come up
to a beautiful baby deer.
It's super cute.
And you manage to get
really, really close to it,
closer than you've ever been.
And you decide you are
going to take a picture.
Now this is going to be the
best picture you've ever taken.
So you slowly carefully take
your phone out of your pocket,
push the power button, and
your phone is out of batteries.
So not only do
you miss the shot,
but then you realize you're
not exactly sure where you are.
And you were really
counting on your phone
to help you navigate back.
And all of a sudden, the woods
look like a much scarier place.
So I think the point here
is that battery life is
extremely important to users.
In fact, one in three users say
the battery life is the number
one problem on their device.
It's the number one problem.
This is also apparent
in statistics
we track about location.
So a large percentage
of users have
decided to completely disable
location on their device.
And when asked them why, they
said power was the main reason.
Now this is a problem
for every developer
in this room who uses location.
Since when location is disabled,
just a lot of stuff breaks.
From navigation, to
context aware apps,
even the weather
just doesn't work
whenever location is disabled.
But I think more importantly,
our users turning off location
means that they're not happy
with the experience they're
getting.
And we don't want that.
We want users to
absolutely love location.
So we've taken a really close
look at power consumption,
and here's what we found.
Well for one thing,
location is used a lot.
The location APIs currently
allow applications to request
location at virtually any time.
So every bar you
see here is a device
doing some kind of
location related work.
Now we can analyze the cost of
these using something called
Android Power Primitives.
Now that is something
I'm really excited
speaking with you today about.
This the first time we've
talked about these externally.
So you can think of
Power Primitives as a way
to understand the fundamental
building blocks of power
on an Android device.
And we can use these
to really understand
how location power is computed.
Here are the four basic
operations that consume power
when using location.
When we first have
to wake up the device
to perform some
work, we then have
to get some location
signals, like Wi-Fi and GPS.
Then we have to run some
computation on the CPU.
And then finally,
maybe go to the network
to get some more
model information.
And we can understand
the cost of all of these
by using the Power Primitives.
So this is the cost of every
single one of these operations.
There's a lot going on
here, so let me highlight
the most important ones.
Well first, using the cell
network is extremely expensive.
This is why the locations stack
has been heavily optimized
to cache data locally
whenever possible
and try to avoid going to the
network by computing things
locally.
Also obtaining location
signals is expensive.
For example, the first fix
for GPS can cost quite a bit.
This is why we
usually tend to prefer
doing Wi-Fi scans instead.
But unfortunately, Wi-Fi scans
are not really cheap either.
So what we've been
doing is try to reduce
the costs of these as much
as possible by limiting which
channels we look at
when doing a Wi-Fi scan
as well as spending the
least amount of time
possible on each channel.
But we are coming up to some
physical limits to how much
we can optimize here.
So in summary, we
see that power is
extremely important to users.
Unfortunately,
location is not cheap.
And we're coming up
to some pretty hard
physical constraints as
to where we can optimize.
And as well, there are
some amazing features
being built using location.
So with all of
this in mind, we're
introducing a
significant change to how
location works in
the Android O release
called Background
Location Limits.
This is something we're
really excited about,
as it drastically improves
battery life for Android users
while also allowing great
location use cases to be built.
And now we will
come speak to you
about some of the details of
background location limits.
As well as how you can
prepare your application
for the Android O.
WEI WANG: Thanks a lot, Marc.
My name is Wei Wang.
I'm a Software Engineer in
Location and Contacts Team.
I'm going to talk about
Background Location
Limits in Android O release, the
power improvements to location
APIs, and where and how you
can prepare your application
for these changes.
So first, let's take a
look at the difference
between foreground apps
and background apps.
For location purpose,
an application
is considered as foreground
when it is actually
interacting with
users, which means
it's either running
a foreground UI
or running a foreground service
that the user cares about.
Otherwise, the application
is considered as background
from location's perspective.
So our study showed background
apps are the major contributor
to location power issues.
Now before the
Android O release,
there were no limits
to background location
usage, which means any app can
request location at any time.
Now this causes several
different problems.
Of those apps, many applications
request location aggressively
when they run in background,
or they leak a fast foreground
location when they switch
from foreground to background.
So beginning from O, we
are going to impose limits
to the background apps.
So I would like to
emphasize, these limits
apply to background
location only.
And it would not affect your
foreground location usage.
So lets start with
location providers.
Location providers
are the main entry
for requesting location updates.
We have too many location
providers, the Fused Location
Provider in Google Play Services
and the Location Manager
on the platform.
So starting from Android O,
for both location providers,
apps running in background
cannot trigger location
computation more frequently
than a couple of times per hour.
For [INAUDIBLE] API in
Fused Location Provider
a few more location
computations are allowed.
But the delivery time is going
to be the same as non-based
in API.
For Fused Location
Provider, we are also
going to take advantage
of Wi-Fi connection
to reduce location computation.
And no new location
computation would
be performed when a device is
connected to the same access
point, which indicates the
user has not moved much
from the previous location.
So this provides significant
battery improvements
when a user is at home or his
work with Wi-Fi connection.
So with similar
strategy in mind,
we also applied very similar
changes to Geofencing.
The responsiveness
of Geofence will
increase from tens of
seconds to a few minutes.
But the power is going to be
10 times more power efficient
than the previous releases.
So we also used similar
Wi-Fi connection approach
and can now provide better
transition detection
when a user leaves
home or leaves work.
All the changes I mentioned
apply to all background
apps running on
Android O release
regardless of the
target SDK version.
We believe this is
a tested approach
to provide our users with
immediate battery improvement
when they upgrade to O.
Now you may be wondering,
how do these changes look
like on a real device?
So Marc showed you an example
of location activities before O.
Now let's take a
look at how things
change after applying all the
background location limits.
So you can see, there are
much fewer location activities
during the same period.
In fact, after around
6:00 PM, when a device
connected to a static
Wi-Fi access point,
there were no
location computation.
But it was still able to
provide us fresh locations.
Because we know that the device
is connected to the same Wi-Fi,
so the user had
not moved far away.
So the battery consumption
for background location
is much, much better
now on O. So I've
talked about a few changes
to background locations.
And the battery improvements,
especially, looks really good.
But as a developer you
might be wondering,
this means fewer locations
coming to my app.
What should I do?
So let's talk about
a few approaches
that you can take to
make your application
ready for background changes.
The first, consider only
requesting foreground location.
So does your app
really need location
when it is not
interacting with users?
If it only needs user location
to search restaurant near by,
then you could always
request a location after user
opens the app.
No background location limits
would apply in this case.
And you can get frequent
location updates as before.
So we are also
working on reducing
the kernel caching latency
to ensure a better foreground
location.
On the other hand,
if your application
needs to trigger when
the user enters or exits
a given area, such as
automatically turning off
air conditioning when a
user leaves with home,
you can use Geofence
API to detect
that user has entered the world
or exited an area of interest.
As mentioned before, the
Geofencing API in Android O
is 10 times more power efficient
than the previous releases.
If your application needs
to collect a user's location
and display the location
history at a later stage,
such as Google Maps
Timeline, then you
can use Batching API and
Field Location Provider.
Batching allows location system
to collect location signals,
such as Wi-Fi scans, at low
power with a higher rate,
then compute and deliver
locations to the client
only when needed.
This way we can consolidate
all the network inquiries
to save battery.
So let's take a look
at an example of how
to enable location batching.
[INAUDIBLE] you will need to
create a location request.
You'll set the
interval to 10 minutes.
The key here is to set the
MaxWaitTime time to a few times
more than the request interval.
So this allows the
location provider
to collect location
signals every 10 minutes
but delivers the locations to
the client every 30 minutes.
Now finally as a last resort
if you really, really need
[INAUDIBLE] to
foreground locations
when you're running
in background,
you can start a
foreground service
by showing an
ongoing notification.
Applications showing
ongoing notifications
are considered as
foreground apps.
So background location
limits would not apply.
To start a foreground
service, create a notification
and the supply a
PendingIntent to record when
the notification is clicked.
By calling the foreground all
of your apps tagged as Android O
calls that foreground service.
The service becomes
foreground while you're
showing ongoing
notifications to the users.
Now do not forget to
stop foreground service
if foreground location
is non-needed animal.
OK
So far I've talked about
background location
limits on the Android O device.
How about Pre O devices?
The system did not impose
any limits on Pre O devices.
So we rely on your
best practices
to make sure the
background location
power is at a reasonable state.
The optimization you do, such
as is request only foreground
locations, use Geofencing
instead of frequent location
polling, using Batching if
an immediate location is not
needed.
However, will be
applied to Pre O devices
to make the background
location uses battery usage
at a reasonable state.
So in summary, I've talked about
background location limits,
battery improvements
for locations on O,
and several different
ways to make your apps
ready for those changes.
Now let's switch gear to
talk about location accuracy
improvements.
[APPLAUSE]
For the past years,
we have been keeping
on improving location
accuracy, especially
for indoor environments.
Our data showed a 40% and 20%
percent accuracy improvement
for the past two years.
This year we are on
good track of achieving
another 40% accuracy
improvements and another 40%
accuracy improvements
in a year 2018.
In fact, our accuracy
would be good enough
for indoor navigation.
Now let me show you
a couple of videos
to demonstrate our indoor
accuracy improvements.
So the left side radio is
running on the current Fused
Location Provider.
The right one is running on a
version that is coming soon.
The blue dotted line shows the
route that the user is taking.
The blue dot is unit's
current location.
Now let's play the first video.
So you can see the
blue dot aligned
with the user's real
location really, really well
at the start.
But as user went
indoors the location
jumped and divert a lot
from user's real location.
Now let's play the second video
to see how things improved.
So this time the payload
out aligned with the routes
perfectly, even when the
yielder was deep indoors.
Now when the user makes the
turn, you can see [INAUDIBLE]
with them move
really, really well.
So we are very excited about
the accuracy improvements.
And we hope that this can
bring better opportunity
to your application.
Another area we are
truly excited about
is this support of
the GNSS measurements
in this environment
in Android any release
on location manager.
Developers can now
get more information
such as [INAUDIBLE] ranges,
Doppler's, and [INAUDIBLE]
other than just the position.
That information can be used
to build value-added apps,
such as much much more
precise positioning using
[INAUDIBLE] fast measurements.
We also provide the tools
to log, analyze, and realize
all these GNSS measurements.
You can use these tools
when prototyping your apps
and answer questions like, which
satellites are you [INAUDIBLE]?
How strong are the
individual measurements?
How accurate are the
[INAUDIBLE] measurements?
We are very eager to see more
user cases of the [INAUDIBLE]
and measurements
in the ecosystem.
So far I've talked about
accuracy improvements
to Fused Location Provider, the
new APIs for GNSS measurements.
We hope developers can take
good use of these improvements
to build better location apps.
With that, I will
hand it over to Marc
to talk about
activity recognition.
[APPLAUSE]
MARC STOGAITIS:
Well, Thanks, Wei.
So activity recognition
provides your application
with contextual cues
as to what users
are doing in the real world.
Now these are the activities
we currently detect.
This is something I'm
extremely proud of,
as just a few years ago
this list was much smaller.
So you can break it down
into fitness type activities,
like running or biking,
device contexts,
like are you in a vehicle,
as well some gestures,
like the tilt-to-wake
gesture on your watch.
And today I'd like
to talk to you
about some upcoming
improvements to our accuracy,
simplifications we're
making to our APIs
to make them much easier to
use, as well some new activities
will be detecting.
So let's start with
accuracy improvements.
Well, the world of
machine learning
has seen some amazing
results from the use
of deep neural networks.
And activity recognition
is no exception.
We've developed a
Deep Activity Neural
Net, which significantly
improves the accuracy
of activity recognition.
Now this makes it
much easier for you
to build contextual
applications,
and it also looks really cool.
We're also doing
some big improvements
to our APIs to make them
easier for you to use.
Now the current
Activity Recognition API
provides you with raw low level
access to activity signals.
Now this is very
powerful and flexible.
But it also means that simple
things can be hard to do.
So let me show you what I mean.
Now let's say you're
building a car assistant
app that allows users to
interact with their device
hands free when in a car.
Now a simple way
to do this would
be to write an if
statement that says,
if the activity is
in-vehicle, start my app.
And if it's not
in-vehicle, close my app.
So let's talk about
some of the pitfalls
that you'll encounter
if you do this.
So the user starts in a vehicle
with a confidence of 80%.
Great, so far so good.
You launch your application.
And it keeps driving
with a confidence of 100.
Everything's
working well so far.
And then they stop at a light,
and you get a still activity.
Now that simple if
statement from earlier
wouldn't have taken
this into account,
and the app would have closed.
So you say, OK, let
me update my filter
to deal with the still
while in-vehicle use case.
So the user continues to drive
and then hits a speed bump.
And we misdetect it as biking.
Now we worked really hard
to avoid misclassifications.
But sometimes they
are unavoidable
in this raw low level API
we're providing that has
very little filtering in it.
Now you can write
a filter to try
to deal with things like this.
Because if you look
at the history,
well, there's a lot of
driving in the past.
The biking confidence
is very low.
So 55 is pretty low.
And there was no
activity that you
would expect between
driving and biking,
like something like walking.
But writing this
is getting pretty
cumbersome and complicated.
OK so the user
continues to drive,
and now you get a tilt event.
Now a tilt event is
a strong indication
that the user's activity
is about to change.
It tends to happen when a user
goes from sitting to standing.
So you can take that into
account into a filter.
And then finally, the
user starts walking.
And you can finally
close your application.
Now writing a filter to
deal with all of this
is pretty tricky.
It requires a lot of
training data to get right.
Well we're making this much
easier with the Activity
Transition API.
Now it takes a messy raw
activity signal, like this,
and turns it into
simple transitions.
You get a vehicle
start event when
the user starts driving
and a vehicle end
event when they stop.
That's it.
We take care of all the
filtering behind the scenes.
This means by using this
Activity Requisition Transition
API, you can write that simple
if in-vehicle statement.
And your app should just work.
Now I'd like to
quickly talk about some
of the new activities that
we're working on detecting.
So we're really
excited to announce
that we've developed a road
versus rail vehicle detection
algorithm that can tell the
difference between a car
and a train for example.
So we think this will lead to
some very powerful applications
that help users
during public transit
as well as improve
in-car experiences.
We can't wait for
you to try it out.
And I'm also really
proud to announce
that we're now able to
automatically detect
strength training exercises.
This means that you
can walk into a gym
and have your entire workout
automatically tracked for you.
This makes it really easy to
keep track of your progress
over time and make
adjustments along the way.
It's available in
the LG Watch Sport.
And we'll be rolling it
out to more devices soon.
So in summary,
activity recognition
will be bringing you improved
accuracy, simplified APIs,
and new activities
in the coming month.
And now I'd like to invite
Steve to talk about how we'll
be making this, as well
as other contextual use
cases, run at ultra low power.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE MALKOS: Thanks, Marc
Hi my name is Steve Malkos.
I'm the Technical Program
Manager for the Android
Location and Context Team.
Before I start talking about
Android Sensor Hub and context
hub runtime environments,
can I see a show of hands?
How many people here know what
the Android Sensor Hub is?
Not that many of you.
That's all right.
Because when you
leave here today,
you'll all be experts
in this field.
Marc just showed us some
really cool examples
on how activity
recognition works.
We've launched some amazing
features in Android.
Things like physically tracking
where you parked your car,
tracking activities like
running, walking, and biking,
and providing you with
relevant information that's
important to you at a
specific moment in time,
like pulling up a
train schedule as you
arrive at the train station.
But we found that bringing
some of these factors, some
of the biggest limiting
challenges here,
has been around power,
consuming power.
That's your battery.
So with the Android Sensor
Hub and Context Hub Runtime
Environment, we're able to
leverage the capabilities
of a low power processor to
make it possible for us to bring
these experiences and more.
We all know that if you
write an application
and it sucks up
the user's battery,
they're going to quickly
uninstall it from their device.
When talking about
power for activities
that happen in an
always-on fashion,
there's always two things at
play, latency and accuracy.
Improving power
means we could run
our apps at a greater frequency
improving on the latencies.
Improving power
also means we can
look at more signals
improving on our accuracies.
So two years ago, we introduced
the Android Sensor Hub
in Marshmallow.
We use this tiny
standalone microcontroller,
that's depicted on a
dime, and connected
all the sensors to it.
And it runs in an
always-on fashion.
We launched this on the
Nexus 5x and the Nexus 6P.
Last year, we worked on
the second generation
of the Android Sensor Hub.
This time, in addition to
connecting all the sensors
to it, we also connected all
the wireless connectivity
components.
And we launched this on
the Pixel and the Pixel XL.
As mentioned earlier,
the Android Sensor Hub
runs in an always-on
processing, and it hardly
affects the user's battery.
Context Hub Runtime Environment
provides a common platform
for us to leverage these
low power processors.
So with the Context
Hub's common platform,
we created mini-applications
that we call Nanoapps.
So let's go through a
couple of Nanoapp examples.
All the activity recognition
APIs, like running,
walking, biking,
in-vehicle have been
ported from the main
application processor
into the Android Sensor Hub.
And we'll take a look at how
activity recognition both saves
on power and improves
on our accuracies
when running as a Nanoapp.
If you were to run
activity recognition
on the main
application processor,
it consumes a ton of
power, about 5 milliamps.
When we introduced Sensor
Batching in the Android
Operating System, we were
able to cut that number down
into half.
But it's still running on the
main application processor.
We took it from 5
milliamps to 2.5 milliamps.
Running these same algorithms
in the Android Sensor Hub
as a Nanoapp, costs
us a fraction of that
power, 300 microamps.
And because the
power is so low, we
can now run these algorithms
at a faster frequency improving
on our latencies
and our accuracies.
Another example of a Nanoapp
that I'd like to highlight
is Geofencing.
There are tons of Geofencing
applications in the market
today that use the
Google Geofencing APIs.
We've now offloaded
these algorithms
from the main
application processor
into the Android Sensor Hub.
And we did this by connecting
the Wi-Fi chip, GPS,
and the cell modem into the
low power compute domains.
This brings us a
significant power savings,
and it improves
on our latencies.
And finally on the
Android Sensor Hub,
let's talk about gestures.
We added tons of gestures.
Gestures like lift
to check phone,
double tap to check phone,
flip camera, and more.
I'm going to highlight
one of the examples.
And let's focus on flip camera.
If I launch my camera
app and double twist it,
it will change from outward
facing to selfie mode.
I have to do this.
All right everybody on the
count of three say cheese.
One, two, three, cheese.
This gesture is only
possible because it
runs in an always-on fashion
in the Android Sensor Hub.
Any application could
register and use
this private sensor type today.
To close on the Android
Sensor Hub with CHRE,
devices on the market that
support this automatically
get a common platform
that takes advantage
of lower power,
lower latencies, in
an always-on compute fashion.
And these Nanoapps can overcome
some of the new paradigms that
have been introduced
with our latest operating
system, like background
location limitations.
We're really excited about this
platform and the new use cases
that can be enabled from it.
I'm going to switch gears now.
And go from that
to Android sensors,
highlighting four key items.
And then Souvik is going
to come up and talk
to us about the compass.
Dynamics sensors, this was
introduced in Android N.
It allows us to expose sensors
that are not necessarily
bundled with the device.
And it lets us connect
them via Bluetooth and USB.
For example, you can now
attach a high quality
inertial measurement
unit to your device,
a biological sensor, an
environmental sensor.
And your apps could
natively see them.
This year, we're standardizing
on these interfaces
for dynamic sensors.
So the sensors that
you build can now
leverage the Android platform
and make it easier for you,
as an application
developer, to access them.
Direct Sensors
Channel, initially
targeted for VR and
camera applications.
Simply put, Direct
Sensors Channel
is minimal latency
between the sensor
driver and your application by
bypassing the sensor service.
Accessing sensors directly
with direct sensors channel,
the programs that you develop
will have the smallest amount
of sensor latencies.
Ever experience a VR application
with a skewed horizon?
Similar to uncalibrated
magnetometer
and uncalibrated
gyroscope, we introduced
uncalibrated accelerometer.
Last year, we wrote our
own calibration algorithms
for the accelerometer.
And we open sourced this to
the ecosystem with the hopes
and goals that a
device manufacturer
would build better devices.
And we're seeing
results like this.
After applying the
calibration algorithms,
the VR landscape is straight.
The final sensor feature
that I'm going to focus on
is Wrist Sensor, now called
Low Latency Off-body Detector.
Simply, we have a reliable way
to detect when the watch is
on the wrist or off the wrist.
The targeted use
cases for this is low
friction authentication to
your phone, no passcodes
for payments, and
changing the UI behavior
when the watch is
off your wrist,
like sleeping the watch
more aggressively when its
off your wrist.
So before I had the
microphone over,
I want to quickly note
that we use sensors today
in almost every application.
And our commitments to
them at Google is huge.
We'll continue to invest
in the sensor's future.
These features, like Dynamic
Sensors, Direct Sensors
Channel, calibration algorithms,
and Low Latency Off-Body
Detector, are just a
few highlighted examples
on what we're working on.
We'll be adding more sensor
features in the future.
With that, let's continue
on the sensor theme
and hear from Souvik
on the compass.
[APPLAUSE]
SOUVIK SEN: Thanks, Steve.
I'm Souvik.
And I'm a Software Engineer on
Android Location and Context
Team.
And I'm here to talk
about heading and bearing.
So what is heading and bearing?
So bearing tells you, as
a context, the direction
that the user is traveling.
And heading is the direction
that the user's phone
is pointing.
So heading and
bearing are different.
Heading is something that if
you are standing at a stoplight
and you pan your phone around to
find which direction you should
walk, that's when
you're heading changes.
And your bearing
is not necessarily
changing at that point.
So how do you realize
bearing and heading?
It depends a lot on
the user's context.
So if you're an
application who might
gain by knowing the
direction of the user,
think very hard about what
context you are after.
Because based on that
you want to select
between heading or bearing.
Let's see how we're doing
that in Android Google Maps.
So in Android Google
Maps, the blue dot arrow
used to always point
to the user's heading,
essentially which direction
your phone is pointing.
Now what we found is that
the user's expectation
from the blue dot
arrow is much more.
When they are stationary,
like standing still or panning
their phone around, they
want to see their heading
from the blue dot arrow.
Perhaps because they
are trying to figure out
which direction to go next.
If they're traveling, like
in a car, or in a bicycle,
or even when they're running,
they want to see the bearing.
That is the direction
that they are moving.
Because they want
to, perhaps, verify
that the direction they're going
towards is actually correct.
And more importantly,
they want us
to communicate the uncertainty
in heading or bearing.
Because if you're not certain,
if the heading are bearing
information that we are giving
to the user it is not correct,
the user wants to look
around, and orient themselves,
and be diligent about this.
So how do we do this?
To distinguish between
stationary and traveling,
we can use the Activity
Recognition API,
like Marc just talked about.
You can know when the user is
stationary versus traveling
and choose between heading
and bearing based on that.
Now to determine
the uncertainty--
note that bearing is
based on location.
So you can see what
the location speed is,
and what the
location accuracy is.
And based on that,
you can determine
the bearing is correct or not.
But how do you find
heading uncertainty?
To understand that, let's
see how heading is actually
being computed.
So heading today is estimated
based on the phone's compass.
And as many of you know, if you
know the phone's compass can
be very unreliable
in presence of metal
objects or externally
electromagnetic fields.
Simple cases, for example,
if you're in a car,
or you're charging your phone.
Or even simple things,
like you keep your phone
next to your laptop,
it's possible
that the phone's compass will
become uncalibrated and hence
become unreadable.
And all of this ties to
the heading uncertainty
that we're after.
So in a nutshell what we found,
by looking at a lot of data,
is that heading
uncertainty really
is about what is the
environmental uncertainty
in which your device is at.
Now to understand the
environmental uncertainty,
we found machine learning
can actually help us.
There is only a few kinds of
involvement of uncertainty
[INAUDIBLE] that are after.
And if you have enough
data, machine learning
can tell when there is anomaly.
And hence when the
compass is correct
and when the compass is not.
And that ties into
heading uncertainty.
We can tell the
user, your heading
is probably not correct because
the compass is unreliable.
And moreover, now,
because we know
when the compass
is unreliable, we
can go back to other kinds
of sensors like gyroscope.
And this in return, actually
improves the accuracy
significantly.
So now that we know the
heading uncertainty,
let's see how we can communicate
that in Android Google Maps.
So before in Google Maps, we
had this pointy cone, which
will always point to heading.
But now, because we know
the heading uncertainty,
we have a Cone UI where
the width of the cone
now tells you what is the
uncertainty in heading.
If it's too wide, you know that
the heading is probably not
correct.
And hence, you can look around
and try to orient yourself.
If the cone is
narrow, you know it
is correct you can just use
it for your own travels.
Beyond Android
Google Maps, if you
are an application
who might benefit
by knowing the user's
direction, and also
the uncertainty in a
more correct fashion,
we're happy to announce
that this is something
we're going to bring
in for all applications
through the Fused
Location Provider API.
With this, I will
hand over to Steve
to talk about the future of
Android Location and Context.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE MALKOS: Thanks, Souvik.
I love talking about the future.
So let's talk about the
presence with regards
to testing location quality.
Because that's the key to
making future improvements.
Over the past few
years we've gotten
very serious with regards
to testing at Google.
We've built up massive
labs and real time tests
from around the world
measuring our location quality.
For example, we run running
tests, walking tests, biking
tests, stationary tests, testing
both indoors and outdoors.
When driving near
tall buildings,
it's very common for
your GPS position
to jump, lag, or even drift.
At Google, we use very expensive
military grade inertial
measurement unit that gives us
centimeter level accuracies.
That gives us this ground truth.
That's the image at the top,
the San Francisco test setup.
The image at the bottom shows
our running and pedestrian test
setups.
The output from these
tests is the graph,
where we show a
cumulative distribution
function on the position errors
from each device, as measured
from the ground truth.
Project Elevation, before
talking about this,
I want to quickly
note about a service
that we launched last year
called Emergency Location
Services in Android.
This service gives
us the ability
to use the computed
location in Android
and send it to
emergency responders
during an emergency situation.
So for example, if you dial
911, or 112, on your handset
the computed
position from Android
will go to carrier's network
and public safety answering
points for those carriers who
sign up for this free service.
With that in mind,
Project Elevation.
Many places around the world,
like downtown San Francisco,
when you're deep indoors
your 2D Lat and long
are just not enough.
GPS altitude works great when
you're outdoors but barely
works, if at all, deep indoors.
And we especially
need it when we're
in environments like this.
So with Google's Machine
Learning Algorithm's Anonymized
Crowd sourced Models,
we'll soon be launching
Project Elevation this year.
This service will
first be utilized
by our Emergency Location
Services in Android,
where we hope to see first
responders benefiting off
of it.
And then we'll also launch it
as part of the standard Android
Location Altitude Outputs.
So you as a developer could
get access to this as well.
We'll also bring a new class
of 3D accurate indoor location.
You heard part of this from Wei.
By using Wi-Fi, GPS,
cellular, PDR, IMU, altimeter,
we're just around the
corner from launching
this massive improvement.
And we'll get there, again, by
using Google's Machine Learning
Algorithm's Anonymized
Crowdsourced
Models to give us these better
accuracies, where we can now
navigate indoors.
Then once we have this all
running on the main application
processor, we'll port it down
into the Android Sensor Hub
because that's the key,
five meters at zero seconds
time to first fix
at ultra low power.
The GPS geek inside of
me gets really excited
when we talk about dual
frequency GNNS receivers.
L1 plus L5 signals, what
does this mean to you?
Better GPS performances.
We'll bring this
into smartphones
in the next couple of years.
And we'll do so for
the following reasons.
Better ranges is for
multipath mitigation.
Because we'll be using
a higher chipping rate,
10x higher, it will give
us unprecedented frequency
diversity using the L1
and L5 signals together.
Our Android O APIs
already have full support
for multi frequency
GNNS receivers.
This enables many use cases.
I'm just going to highlight
two, better downtown
urban canyon
performances, no more
positions on the wrong
side of the street,
post-process decimeter
level accuracies.
Any application that needs
really precise location
will benefit off this,
like fitness applications,
traffic info, and more.
So at work, we get to
work on some really cool
amazing new stuff.
Let's put this all together.
The future will become more
and more contextually aware.
We'll continue to add more
signals into the Android Sensor
Hub.
We've already achieved Activity
Recognition and Geofencing.
Next we're going to add
the Fused Location Provider
awareness, places, and more.
We'll do this with deep neural
networks, machine learning
algorithms, and our
personalized models
with the goals of
helping you make
deeper experiences to your
users in your applications.
By adding all these
signals, we'll
reach a point of location
and context singularity.
Where you'll be able to write
applications that simplify user
interactions, help augment
human memory and knowledge,
and your users having a better
understanding of themselves.
I'm truly excited
about this future
and all these possibilities.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]